we've been hearing more and more about
the fighting intensifying in the east
what is the latest on the ground there
well we've been focusing on several
donetsk um and actually in truth the
borders the boundaries haven't changed a
great deal is incredibly intense
fighting on one side you've got the
russians over matching ukrainians with
10 times as much artillery as the
ukrainians have but the dogged
resistance of the ukrainians is largely
getting this to grind into a standstill
although there are some horrendous
casualties emerging it's really becoming
a bit of a meat grinder the other thing
we're seeing up to the north there is
kharkiv if you remember some time ago
the russians were also pushing on
kharkiv and ukrainians have very
successfully pushed them back again
we've seen a few more uh explosions in
kharkiv and there was a conjecture that
maybe that was the russians re-attacking
what looks far more likely is the
russians are relatively short they've
been brutally mauled on the battlefield
they're trying to move uh folks down to
reinforce their position at several
donetsk and that would risk leaving
their flanks exposed if ukraine pushed
even further so it looks more likely
that the artillery fire is just to keep
the ukrainian heads down um whilst they
reinforce severedness but the fighting
is pretty severe um as you'd expect and
actually emotionally for both sides the
intensity is taking its toll on both the
ukrainian side and and the russian side
but of course the ukrainians are
fighting for their homeland they're
massively well motivated whereas of
course the russians a bunch of
conscripts who are still probably asking
us tens of thousands of casualties
mounting up why are we here
and also nato consistently saying that
they want to de-intensify the situation
and avoid a wider conflict with russia
but today we heard from the new head of
the british army that its troops they've
told its troops that they must prepare
to fight in europe once again so what's
changed well i think we have to set the
context here i think the war has
gradually slipped down the media agenda
somewhat you have to search further and
further down to to find it there are
also some uh leaders in the
international stage i won't quote them
but who clearly um would like this war
to be concluded quickly um you know get
president zelensky to conclude a deal
around the donbass and the crimea and
then all of a sudden fuel prices can
return to their normal level grain can
report to its normal level inflation can
be controlled and get on with domestic
issues the problem with that is it's not
a european war it's putin's war and it's
only a person who understands what his
ambitions are is putin himself and i
think more worryingly of of late putin
has started he started with a special
operation then it became an invasion uh
he's now starts to refer to peter the
great an analysis of himself being like
that well peter the great was one of the
architects of the former soviet union
he's also talked about the former um
soviet states some of the um the states
up in the baltics here and also down
through um the on the boundary of russia
talking to them being part of historic
russia uh with a clear threat that um
they're next and i think that's one of
the reasons why the prime minister and
the secretary general are talking about
this potentially being a much longer war
i was talking to the defense attache to
russia uh literally only a week ago and
he was saying one of the things we
really underestimated in the west when
the soviet union fell
the russia was left with massively
battered pride the pensions weren't
being paid salaries weren't being paid
they felt devastated as a proud nation
putin has come in as a
new leader he controls all the media and
seems to want to restore russian
greatness and that resonates well with
his his domestic audience so it could be
that this wall being concluded with the
donbass down to the crimea and a swathe
of land but it appears increasingly
likely this is the first chapter in a
long series of chapters about russian's
intent to re-establish the russian
empire and the worrying thing for that
is up to the north here estonia latvia
and lithuania now fall under the
protective umbrella of nato and
therefore any threat to those nations
would be a threat to nato nato has to be
prepared and that's one of the reasons
why you're seeing an increase in nato
activity and some more stoic
narrative from some of the military
leaders